it's a 24-7 type of operation we're
published in five thousand stories a day
now fit we don't write all five thousand
stories but they are made up in roughly
three or four different buckets
obviously the first bucket the most
important bucket are ones that are right
it written read write write it I written
by our our staff it's a staff of
full-time and part-time online people
that was originally 375 journalists
we've now combined the offline and
online stabs together so we're pumping
up around seven hundred journalists that
are going to be reporting on some
regular fashion throughout the course of
a week or a month on the site and they
all write a great many stories we also
have wire services which will contribute
you know the regular sort of what
happened and when type of story and then
we'll have content partners and at this
point I think we're up over 250
different content partners that will
file to the site and variably those
filters that we place on those partners
are ones that make the selections that
do appear on the site more for zeen if
you will but those partners will range
everything from a paid content org to
Oxford analytica which is a company that
reviews through the world economic and
social political situation on a daily
basis and then everything in between
so we'll use web analytics to measure
our web traffic every minute of the day
in fact we're looking at that on our
intraday basis we'll look at it from a
daily snapshot at weekly snapshot in a
monthly step snapshot as well but
fundamentally that you know the editors
are constantly reviewing that and making
decisions based upon that in terms of
what goes where in terms of placements
the popularity will range and vary
depending what's happening in the world
so as you might guess you know around
the middle of September of last year
through now there's been a higher degree
of interest in finance stories and in
market stories there wasn't interest
before but interest has spiked as we've
seen you know the world sort of implode
and explode and then hopefully rebound
over the last well six to 18 months
depending on how bad you want to feel
about it other times we'll have an idea
that will you know make news so when we
do one of our major lists one of the
rich lists or one of our celebrities
you'll see huge traffic around that and
then other times it will be you know as
it relates them as the day if a
company's had a major announcement or a
major breakthrough or hopefully not but
if it goes through some serious issues
there'll be a fair amount of traffic
around stories about that happen